♪ (intro music) ♪
The transform widget
can transform even a simple app
into something amazing.
Transforms like this are possible
because Flutter does its own rendering.
Do you want a menu icon
rotated 45 degrees?
A fancy animated transition?
Maybe a bouncy carousel?
Or even a cool menu?
All of these things use Transform widgets.
To rotate something 45 degrees,
just wrap it in a Transform widget
using Transform's Rotate constructor.
Other simple transforms are Scale
and Translate.
There are many more
less common transformations.
You can create them by building
a four-by-four transformation
matrix explicitly.
Here is a Skew transform.
Here is a matrix for doing 3D perspective.
Perspective works
particularly well in animations.
Here's another example of perspective
but applied to an entire app.
To build an app that does this,
see the link for Perspective on Flutter
in the comments for this video.
For more information
on the Transform widget,
see flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪